hey everyone this is Kevin from the test
website comm and today we're continuing
our coverage of the 1972 World Chess
Championship between Bobby Fischer and
buddy Spassky up into this point games 1
through 10 is pretty been one-sided but
these Vaska did come out strong with the
victory in the first game Bobby Fischer
forfeited the second game and then since
then Bobby Fischer's been on a roll and
after ten games Bobby Fischer has a
three-point advantage six in f1 - Bobby
Fischer birdie capacity has three and a
half points so going into game number 11
Bobby Fischer looking to pretty much put
a nail in the coffin but he's fast keep
looking to come back and try to have a
go at this title so but he's fast he's
going to have the white pieces here and
start out with pawn to e4 if you
remember some of our earlier Series pawn
to e4 is not very common for but he's
fast e that's very common for Bobby
Fischer but buddy Spassky did not play a
lot of efore we see Bobby Fischer
respond pawn to c5 to Sicilian so very
similar to what we saw in game 7 and in
game 7 we actually saw the poison pond
variation and Bobby Fischer would go on
to have a to pawn advantage but not be
able to have a win so they did draw that
and we see a very similar opening from
both players nice to f3 pawn to d6 at
night up here to d4 after Knight to d4
that f6 then we get into the niger so
pawn to a6 very sharp line stops any of
these Knights or the Bishop coming here
to b5 - very aggressive opening that
you'll see a lot from the Sicilian
players Bishop over here to g5 you in
the dark square Bishop involved into the
game pawn to e6 pawn up here to F 4 and
then Queen down here to b6 this is the
poisoned pawn variation in the knight
defense you can always go back from
watch game 7 if you want to see how they
played that game or there's another
video I created on the poison pawn if
you just want to learn more about that
specific variation but play continued
with Queen to d2 and you don't have to
play Queen to d2 if you wanted to you
always play Knight to b3 and just not
even allow your opponent to come down
here on b2 but but he's fast you decided
okay I'm going to go ahead and play
Queen to d2
have something up his sleeve knowing
that his opponent Bobby Fischer has
never in the history of jazz lost
playing the black pieces in the night or
poison pond so pretty risky I think but
decides he has to be pretty risky
knowing that he is down three points in
at this match so after Queen to d2 which
he queen takes on a b2 and black doesn't
always have to take this poison pawn
here on b2 he has some other options he
could just continue with regular play
night here to c6 that's really his best
option it's not going to be good if he
tries something at Bishop to e7 may seem
somewhat intuitive getting ready to
castle on the Kings side then start to
really put pressure on the Queen side
where he has this Queen some of his
other pieces he'd get involved into the
action because of pawn to e5 this kind
of just blows up the center of the board
after the pawn takes pawn recaptures the
Knights going to come over here to d5
sensitives being attacked and this kind
of opens up the door for afternoon'
exchange that the king is going to have
to come take here on e7 he's kind of
misplaced here not exactly what black
wants to be doing Queen here to g5 so
all in all not really the best move to
play a Bishop to e7 but if you want to
he could have played a just Knight to c6
instead Bobby Fischer being really good
at the poison palm variation is black
besides good to come down here to Queen
to b2 and then at night to b3 and
Spassky even had a couple options here
rook to b1 is probably a safer place
he's going to gain some tempo as far as
getting development Queen here to a3
Queens that doing too much he does give
up eponymous hero but this rook here on
B one controls the semi open file and if
you look on board he has way more
material into the middle of the board of
really attacking his opponent so usually
white can make up for that pawn material
that he decided to give up but instead
decided to play a Knight to b3 and this
is kind of more the trapping lines where
you try to put your opponent in some
really tough situations and hope that
you can trap their queen eventually and
then end up with an easy victory Bobby
Fischer continues with Queen to a3
making sure his queen is in a safe
position and the bishop takes here on f6
if you look back at game number seven
this is the first difference in
a game where but this mask actually
played Bishop to d3 he decided afterward
that wasn't the best variation in this
particular game it really kind of
blocked off his Queen from attacking at
this D file and he wants to make sure
his lighter Bishop is either on e 2 or D
3 so he can castle on the Kings side get
some protection and then allow his other
rook here to really roam free and start
to attack his opponent but decided at
the bishop here on d3 is not the best
square and instead decided first to go
ahead and take here on f6 really take
away the only minor piece that is on the
board that's not on the back rank here
that's tonight here on f6 so that's
going to take here though there's double
pawns here on the F file so all off I
think a pretty good variation change
that buddy Spassky has now he plays
Bishop here to e2 opening up keeping the
door for this Queen to attack on the D
file so to kind of look at it you can
see white is down that Potamus hero but
all of a sudden black keep the castles
on the King side it's not going to be a
say-so he's usually going to keep this
King in the center of the board it's not
going to catch on the Queen side because
you have the C file that's open right
here and all of a sudden White has a
very strong attack he has both of its
nice kind of business over the board he
has a queen all ready to go he can
castle very easily so this is a pretty
good position for buddy Spassky we do
see the pawn come over here to h5 he
could if he wanted to get his queen out
of trouble and could play Queen to b4
after Castle he could queen up here to
b6 check very easy for the King just
come here to h1 but if you look at this
right away Bobby Fischer he's just
moving his queen around he's not really
doing too much and but but he's fast
he's doing exactly what he wants to he's
continuing with this plan Castle get his
King over to his safe square so this
doesn't really help Bobby Fischer as
much as you want to decides to go ahead
and put a little pressure on his
opponent with pawn to h5 since he's not
going to castle on the King side he says
let's go ahead and start to push my pawn
over here see if I can blow these ponds
up start to put pressure since I know my
opponents not going to be castling on
the Queen side of the board so now we
see Cass on the Kings side a knight here
to c6 needs to get some material
involved into the game a king here to H
I'm not really sure I really like team
to h1 here the king is not under any
pressure could have started to attack
the Queen if you wanted to but aside
first apply keen to h1 Bishop to d7 I am
the knight to be one if you kind of read
lots of commentary or if you study this
game before nice to be one was thought
to be very very novel we hadn't really
seen this move in the poisoned pawn
variation up into this point I think it
really caught Bobby Fischer by surprise
him being the expert in this opening you
know when he kind of talked about it it
didn't really seem like he'd studied
this because it's such an odd move you
kind of bring your knight back to be one
blocks off the rook here on a1 it does
attack the Queen but it seems like you
should be able to get free so he's had
to first come here to Queen to be for
attacking the Queen Queen to e3 does not
want to trade off Queens but does want
to block off some of the other squares
that the Queen can go to specifically
this square here on b6 Bobby Fischer now
tries to open up the door for the Queen
to go back on the dark squares playing
pawn to d5 but these pesky takes that
right away because the pawn can't
recapture it's being pinned down I just
scream right here that would take the
king not a legal move so the knight
comes back getting ready to take the
pawn right here then pile up here to see
for just adding more pressure in the
center of the board exactly what he's
fast he wants to do and then nice f6 we
could have seen Queen to d6 but then
nice at c3 Knight down here at five
Queen over here to d3 I think white
definitely has a better position on
board starting to blow up the pawn chain
and Stern's aboard the King here at h1
is very well protected but it's kind of
tough to figure out exactly what the
best move is but Knight to f5 seems okay
but we still don't see a lot of bobby
fischer's pieces working together and
he's going to be facing a lot of
pressure one from his Queen over here
that starting to trapped a little bit
and the King in the center of the board
Queen here it's a d3 upon over here to
h4 starting to push a little bit on the
King side Bishop to g4 and then Knight
over here to a d6 attacking in the
backward pawn here on c4 but that's fine
with bidets vasty he actually wants to
get his knight involved here to d2 so
this just gives him a reason come here
to d2 protect
this backward pawn here on a c4 and then
pawn f5 so attacking the bishop and this
is kind of a defining moment cuz Vinny's
baskis up into this point been putting
all of his pieces in a spot where he can
really put pressure on bobby fischer's
queen and so from here on out he's not
even going to really be caring about too
much else he says yeah I don't care that
my bishops here on g4 and you can attack
it I'm gonna play pawn to a3 okay well
the Queen's gonna have to come back
Queen here to be six if you once you can
also come to Queen to a4 Queen to a5
just loses to the night that's here on
b3 but this thing it's pretty tricky
night up here to c5 checking the Queen
if you will the Queen is going to come
back to a5 then comes up here to d7 we
do see the king capture and then after
some exchange on board it gets pretty
tricky Knight here to b3 pawn up here we
do see the pawn take on g4 and after
this pawn the bishop takes and all of a
sudden the works going to be able to
come here to d1 they're going to be able
to double up and at this Bishop is going
to fall so this is going to be a pretty
good variation for white so Bobby
Fischer although he's in a tough spot I
think he chose correctly with just
bringing the Queen back here to a b6 but
pawn up here to a c5 says yeah you can
move your queen back here to a7 if you
want to but then I'm just going to take
your knight and that's completely fine
with me the sides can't do that clean
down here to b5 does not want to trade
off these Queens right now so Queen over
here to c3 and then we see a nice first
upon takes on a g4 and we could see a
few things from buddy Spassky he could
if you wanted to take with this queen up
here on h8 that could be good but
unfortunately the queen is just over
here by himself and that's really not to
play this plan is to attack this Queen
right here if Mike continues Knight here
to f5 work over here c1 pawn to h3
really putting pressure on his opponent
after the pawn takes Knight comes down
here you can see there's too much
pressure that Bobby Fischer can put on
his opponent just tell me you want to
have to deal with it if instead you
could see the pawn takes here on d6 well
this is just as bad because rook down
here to h6
Knight up here to c5 but then you could
actually see the Queen just come back
here to d7 that's going to be fine for
Bobby Fischer and set-asides
after the pawn takes on a g4 to say pawn
to a4 putting more pressure on his
opponent now as Queen can't really come
back to a7 because it's stuck right here
so he doesn't really have any good move
so he decides to push a little bit on
the King side says if I can't do
anything I'm just going to try my best
to one to last this effort to go ahead
and try to attack you okay Bobby Fischer
loses his Queen here on d5 pawn here - G
- the King takes right here work down
here to h3 attacking the Queen - very
important that but these masca does not
make a mistake in place a Queen to f6 be
a disaster if you plays pawn to d6 and
it allows his Queens that fall and then
all of a sudden F we see some exchanges
on board his opponent is going to have a
much better setup Bobby Fischer has
double bishop on our double Bishop open
board state he has more pawns on boards
it's going to be I think easy victory
for Bobby Fischer so as we come back the
sides okay let's not do anything too
crazy but each masky Queen here to f6
and then Knight down here to fi pawn up
here really really strong attack just
putting too much pressure on his
opponent Queen back for Bishop to c8
pawn takes on e6 and blowing up the
center of the board then work over here
to e1
Bishop to e7 and then rook up here to e6
and says yakking double-barrel Braemar
over here to e1 I just put too much
pressure on you if the bishop comes here
can bring his Queen here the bishop
can't move he can easily take the knight
right after that unless he wants to
allow the work to come over here is
rookie and even do too much on board he
would just die to one of these other
pieces on board so although police mask
II just kind of dominated in his
opponent and this was the first time
that Bobby Fischer had lost with the
poisoned pawn playing as the black
pieces in the knight wharf defense so I
believe Spassky does cut the deficit to
two points going into game 12 Bobby
Fischer cannot be excited with this so
he's going to be looking to come back
with the white
his and really make sure that his
opponent knows that he is real and he's
coming to take this title but hopefully
everyone to enjoy a game 11 one of the
more exciting games if you ever study
the poison pond
people usually point to this game so
it's a good one to always go back
refresh about it is very exciting and if
you haven't played the poisoned pawn
definitely recommend it knives or
defense in the Sicilian thanks for
watching again and I'll see y'all in at
game number 12